[Musique]
Les retombées de Chihuahua Siebler,
nous avons un besoin urgent de repenser cela hors de
mon chemin chasser Walker, nous avons un problème,
il y a une tempête quand nous avons besoin de parler assez,
je verrai mes parents
[Musique]
altitude 25 000 pieds
retombées assumables Merci  Toi Tuffy nous
venons
ego  c'est bon maintenant c'est
bon êtes-vous sûr oui maintenant c'est à gauche
tournez à gauche désolé sur le verrouillage de l'écran sur
[Musique]
qu'attendez-vous pour sauter par
une fenêtre
qu'est-ce que vous pensez qu'il saute par oh
désolé je ne l'ai pas fait - d  bonne chance suma
possibilité de tomber
tourner à gauche à gauche
désolé avait le verrouillage de l'écran sur
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu attends  sauter par
la fenêtre qu'est-ce que tu penses sauter
de lui oh désolé je ne l'ai pas fait - d bonne chance